la voc du bio s'étend aux cosmétiques le
secteur est en pleine croissance même
les grandes marques s'y mettre car
contrairement aux aliments biologiques
les cosmétiques naturels ne sont pas
plus chers que les autres
alors faut-il croire à leurs effets
c'est le dossier de cette édition il est
signé laurence de cher frédéric faure
dans quelques semaines elles vont
envahir l'hexagone ces affiches d'une
campagne de publicité annonce le
lancement d'une nouvelle gamme de
maquillage bio par un géant français de
la beauté marques naturelles dont les
formules sont naturels de 98 à 100% la
cosmétique bio un marché émergent qui
tente l'industrie 30% en plus chaque
année c'est 500 produits nouveaux en
rayon crèmes gels douche et maquillage
on trouve aujourd'hui tout au naturel
c'est un marché émergent
on y croit on espère pouvoir prendre une
belle place sur ce marché
et pour cause comme en agriculture
biologique la cosmétique bio attire le
client comme ce couple qui n'achètent
plus de produits classiques craignent
que ces produits dérivés de l'industrie
chimique qu on nous met dans le dans ces
produits qui peuvent donner d'abord
parce que les allergies des musées comme
ça quand on est allergique ans peut pas
les utiliser
et puis ensuite je sais pas pourquoi son
côté s'est pas voir boire environnement
c'est dégueulasse mais pas facile de
décoder les étiquettes des produits bio
fobio les fabricants sort sur les mots
les noms des laboratoires mais en
regardant de plus près la composition
des produits pas beaucoup d'ingrédients
naturels
alors comment s'y retrouver dans les
enseignes spécialisées
tout est labellisé mais voilà les labels
il y en a plein
l'important c'est quel que soit le
produit c'est de rechercher sur
l'emballage sur le flacon le label donc
c'est le signe de la certification
ici on voit le label cosmébio qui le
label français en france aussi la belle
nature et progrès pour les produits de
marque allemande
on a le label bdih avec ces labels sont
exclus les composants issus de la
pétrochimie parabènes suspectés d'être
cancérigènes éthers de glycol parfum ou
colorants de synthèse silicone et
paraffine
un cosmétique ne peut jamais être bio à
100% car dans sa composition il y a
beaucoup d'eau et des minéraux qui
peuvent être naturel mais pas
certifiable seuls les éléments d'origine
végétale peuvent être cultivées en
agriculture biologique pas plus efficace
qu'un produit classique le cosmétique
bio est il meilleur pour la santé c'est
mieux d'utiliser un cosmétique bio en ce
sens qui aura moins de produits
chimiques à l'intérieur mais il faut
pointer du doigt le fait que les
cosmétiques bio peuvent entraîner des
intolérances des eczémas de contact des
allergies donc bio ne veut pas dire
totalement inoffensif certifié ce qui
peut être biologique
c'est le rôle d'ecocert un organisme
indépendant
aujourd'hui c'est jour de contrôle chez
ce fabricant de cosmétiques bio des
matières premières contre les des
factures l'éplucher pour éviter les
fraudes et quelquefois même des produits
finis des magasins sont analysés en
produisant quatre fois plus qu'il ya
quatre ans ce fabricant cherche toujours
de nouvelles formules les cosmétiques
bio ont évolué laissant place à des
parfums plus agréable qu'il y a dix ans
et une conservation plus longue
on n'utilise pas par exemple de pots de
crème ou six que des flacons airless
dans lesquels n'y a pas d'air donc aucun
risque d'oxydation une garantie
vos conservation d'ici cinq ans un
produit sur 20 sera certifié bio pas
plus chers que les marques de luxe
le bio en cosmétique un bel avenir
devant lui